well these protests which are
essentially anti-government protests
that's how they began have been ongoing
for the better part of
a month now increasingly they've been
gaining momentum and
also we've been seeing scenes of
violence in the
latest protests it happened on tuesday
evening the police dispersed
anti-government protesters from
many of the main roads in tel aviv and
also the main highway known as ilon they
were police on horseback
who were pushing the crowd back
protesters were demonstrating against
the
prime minister benjamin netanyahu's
corruption charges and at the same time
the way he's been handling the whole
covered 19 pandemic which they say is
far from efficient the demonstration
started outside the house of the
minister
of public security he has been calling
for tougher police
measures we came here and we will shout
and we won't use violence as the police
do despite everything the thing that
hurts me most is what the police are
doing
they are people like us with families
but they don't understand the damage
they are doing
i came to protest as i have nothing to
lose i was injured in the army
i have my own business that was shut
down
they closed the entertainment industry
they closed people's businesses
there was just nothing to lose in
earlier this month netanyahu introduced
an aid package that he says he believes
will bring economic safety
to the people of israel affected by
covet 19 at
least for the next year on the issue of
his corruption charges he continues to
maintain his innocence
but the mood is such on the ground here
that we're likely to see demonstrations
like this continuing
at least into the near future